someone who's I just wanna make sure I'm
still what you're asking me it's
somebody who's had dreams themselves had
to give up and so became like a casting
agent and then enjoys crushing other
people's dreams do you think that's
prevalent in this industry whether it's
acting I think it's prevalent every
industry I think it's a human to human
trait most weak small people who make
themselves feel better about their
failure by shall we say actively
assisting in the failure of another
you'll see this even in the corporate
world where there's two types of
employees ok there's the employee that
wants to do well and when they do well
they share what they've learned and then
there's the employee who hoards all
their knowledge they're not going to
share with anybody actually there's a
third then there's a salesperson that's
a whole different animal because its
sales that information could be used by
competitive team made to take you down
so I guess I don't want to let's put
them on a separate Island but in general
you'll see that a lot you'll see that
punitive manager that doesn't want their
best employee to succeed because their
frightful that that person will surpass
them and you're going to find them
anywhere you have to overcome this stuff
these are just normal obstacles in life
and if you fail don't blame it on that
guy he's just one person it's just one
of many land mines and that's the whole
process of overcoming adversity this was
separate successful failure you can't
guarantee an outcome you can't guarantee
that you're going to do well in this
life whether it's a regular corporate
job or tactic if some that try to
guarantee outcomes in this society we
kind of make it fair for the fact of the
matter is there are some that are going
to rise above in spite of the obstacles
and there's others who just give up how
does someone play leap frog or Frogger
with that type of
LD whether it's in the corporate realm
or whether it's in acting they know
someone is holding them down but of
course you can't let them see that you
know that because then contenders what's
the best approach focus focus on the
goal play the game if you see someone is
actively getting in your way you might
want to reconsider moving they're not
the only person it's not the only job
it's not the only gig there's other
paths so I mean unless somebody has got
some this all sounds like a movie script
you know I'm going to stop that person
from succeeding but in general it's just
one person who's going to you know in a
passive aggressive way getting get in
your way but if you feel like that
there's somebody who's getting your way
that recess I mean look different game
comes with rules and some things come
with a package that's kind of the whole
you know dreamers reality that i was
talking about earlier and so you have to
adapt and if you choose not to adapt and
grow and find creative ways around
problems you're probably going to have a
tough time no matter what you do because
life is really all about you know the
journey and getting around those
obstacles and be creative and those who
come up with creative ways do better
you